[Musique]
ils y ont droit
voici double jeu spécial intello avec le
plus intello des rigolos pierre
desproges les deux black est les plus
chouettes de la planète
salt n pepa la parodie kaka de nirvana
verdien govic unique plus le caméraman
laurent baffie essomba fichaux la
maquilleuse chantal ladesou évadés du
théâtre du musée grévin le super expert
françois rollin alias professeur rollin
et le dj philippe corti le meilleur du
pays + michel polac jean d'ormesson et
andré bercoff voici tout bleu jeu
spécial intello je suis réalisateur et
je paie un clip annonçant la fureur de
lire un grand événement organisé par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale et de
la culture
voici le logo la fiche tout le monde est
concerné les jeunes bien sûr et les
moins jeunes
ça se fait dans toutes les régions de
france est déjà en europe et des idées
c'est bien connu ça tombe du livre
bonsoir bienvenue aux folies bergères
pour double je il consent que sur une
chaîne de service public dans une
émission intitulée spécial intello et a
fortiori en pleine fureur de lire
il est bon de rompre pour une fois avec
la trivialité de la télévision et
d'écouté de la poésie celle de françois
rollin qui rend certains qui fend la
nuit de glace soupire funèbres soupire
de braise remous comme il sait si ce ton
nom on murmurait aux cavaliers des
ténèbres casse-couilles venus ardente et
ardent périclès brise enflammé d'un
soleil disparue
de ce rêve évanescent que ton coeur
accomplit que transperce ce trait ou
mourut la colombe le boul
l'oiseau la prise de tête et se chausse
trappes c'est pas la fin c'est pas la
peine si vous croyez qu'il dissimule à
peine pas fier qui ricanent depuis le
début ça c'est lamentable pour une fois
que la télévision fait une bonne place à
la poésie
il faut qu'à la bête qu'il bouffe comme
un plaimont c'est un jour où il mélange
tout ne respectent rien ce garçon là n'a
pas sa place sur une chaîne publique
or voilà voilà maintenant vous
demanderez à dassier titre eastman
pour une fois qu'on essayait de faire
une soirée poésie laurent c'est gagné
[Musique]
et j'en sais
aux yeux polak au ca me fait bien
plaisir pour une fois qu'on peut voir
quelques pas
bah tu aimerais ça michel polac c'est un
pur c'est vrai c'est un exemple pour la
jeunesse 1 il est tellement exemplaire
qui s'est fâché avec tout le monde il
s'est fait virer de partout alors
finalement c'est un exemple mais on peut
le montrer nulle pa c'est pas bien c'est
pas bien pour un exemple j'ai fait le
trait sinon il va encore se barrer bon
alors on va commencer par on va
commencer par un mini débat donc en
forme d'interview parallèle je vais vous
poser à tous les trois à tour de rôle la
même question en commençant par vous
jean d'ormesson
qu est ce qu un intello en tout cas
c'est pas un type qui est plus
intelligente que les os 2 je crois que
ce qui trompe dans le dans le mot
intellectuel c'est qu'on a l'impression
que c'est eux qui sont intelligents
alors ça c'est la première erreur à
éviter je pense que l'intellectuel n'est
pas plus intelligent qu'un garagiste
qu'un banquier ou qu'un balayage des
rues jean de bruges en bougeant d'or
c'est le prénom
savait il y avait mieux là il y avait
mieux parce que je crois que c'était un
canard enchaîné qui qui l'appelait dans
d'ormesson
bien sûr c'était mieux voilà tennis en
battant le bastringue valant 50 ans si
on veut parler sérieusement je pense
qu'un intellectuel est quelqu'un qui met
ce qui ce qui distingue l'intellectuel
c'est pas l'intelligence c'est la
recherche de la vérité et je crois que
l'intellectuel mais en principe la
vérité au dessus de ses intérêts là on a
déjà pour mes deux points interrogés les
intellects en vrai qu'on a six way va
moins loin qu'à l'intellectuel qui
marche générale c'est quelqu'un qui est
brut diplôme agrégé de philo docteur
ès-sciences seul sociologique
professeurs et caetera et en général les
diplômes
ça prouve qu'on a un certain savoir ça
prouve pas du tout qu'on a une
intelligence et pas qu'on peut les gens
en vrai vous savez construire soi même
c'est ce que considère les autres les
importants en bref oui moi je sais pas
moi je ne considère pas bien et il ya un
type sérieux ou par des diplômes à
l'intellectuel c'est bien je n'y a pas
mettre des catégories ou celui-là c'est
vrai dire on s'en fout si le mec
boulogne non mais toi et toi moi oui oui
messieurs dames non pour les pour les
intellectuels ch rigolo et pour les
rigolos juin d'intellectuels
j'en ai squelette est ce que est ce que
vous considérez berckois fait peu là
comme des intellos d'accord on a compris
je veux dire comme ça on va voir ce
qu'ils disent
alors toi est-ce que tu considère jean
d'ormesson et michel polac comme des
intellos moi je crois que non mais je
crois que si tu veux toute personne qui
travaille dans les idées on moi c'est un
intellectuel
bon voilà michel veuillez considérer
comme les intellos tous les deux là jean
d'ormesson non c'est plutôt un romancier
poète quoi tandis que oui berckois s'il
fait plus dans l'intello way et je
revendique genre parce que thébaux
qu'avez vous qu'avez-vous vide important
récemment mois dans l'époque où j'ai des
choses d'abord j'ai dit les choses
privées qu'il est très importante mais
simone j'ai envie de toi non pas ici
mais vous dit dans quelle position
importance à déboucler vous allez dans
le même chemin aucune voyons au pull
bien chaud qu'une caisse qui prend là il
a voulu défendre dubrovnik moi oui c'est
ce que j'allais dire mais bon andrey ou
est-ce que ça vive important examen
huawei passe moi le sel n'aurait tout
territoire sur lequel tu poses les pieds
est un territoire libéré défend le
balèze
ben moi chaque fois que je le peux je
dis que je suis scandalisé par la
non-intervention yougoslavie et qu' il
ya des camps de concentration il ya des
populations massacrées que nous sommes
comme à l'époque de la guerre d'espagne
nous sommes des spectateurs et nous
refusons de donner des armes aux gens
qui se font massacrer et qui nous
demande simplement qu'on les aide pas
avec de l'aspirine avec des tanks et des
avions
faut pas les laisser massacrer mois pour
moi c'est ça qui est important si je
suis un peu intello c'est quand je peux
glisser les petites phrases comme ça moi
j'ai l'impression théoricien continue
comme ça mais j'ai l'impression que vont
dire que les intellectuels sont des gens
shihan c'est pas vrai du tout bon ce ne
sont pas des jeunes en a pas continuer
comme ça on va passer à dernière
question quand êtes vous qu'on vous vous
savez il faudrait reprendre dans les
dents le dans l'histoire tout ce qui a
été dit a regardé un type comme tiers un
bon tiers est un tube qui pensent pour
un grand écrivain grand historien un
grand homme politique
vous savez qu'il avait écrit sur les
chemins de fer des choses inouïes
il avait dit qu'on ne pourrait pas
prendre le chemin de fer parce qu on en
sortirait avec des maladies abominable
que la traversée des tunnels peu
provoquerait des des traumatismes
effrayante
le chemin de fer n'avait absolument rien
à venir voilà un exemple mais vous ouais
moi romance avec des choses très modeste
que ce que je ne me dis tu t'arrêtes de
brancher le vieux parce que c'est trop
cher
zikiz affirmerait est ton ami là par
exemple sont pour la première de droit
de réponse a dit que c'était une
véritable catastrophe nationale qu'on
n'avait pas vu ça depuis le bon balle à
venir là un peu détrempée
on s'arrête là dessus et vous prenez des
berckois non je me suis trompé sur les
choses beaucoup plus graves
farid p bref j'étais persuadé que vous
comme eni tomberait très très vite en
iran comédie ça allait durer un maximum
veut c'est pas de la connerie savoir
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
ben son journal moi je me soucie tête
ont l'exemple quand nasser à
nationaliser le canal de suez le figaro
écrit les arabes n'arriveront pas à
faire fonctionner le canal de suez en
asie n'ont jamais dit qu'ils s'étaient
trompés dans this is in a beaucoup été
coupées ou non les gars devant les tirs
à directeur à l'époque maintenant il en
est le meilleur titre est issu du canada
the ont fait suer le burnous ce menacer
le burnous ce qui nous fait suez est là
c'est bien ça c'était bien quand es-tu
comtois toujours
toujours j'aime ça j'aime jouer serré on
l'a même des lueurs qu'elles font aucune
lueur parce que je trouve que la
connerie et la forme moderne de la
liberté t'es con té à l'abri et tu peux
dire ce que tu veux personne t'emmerde
c'est très important
donc je revendique non en fait mais
libre canton de bêtises et puis n'oublie
jamais je m'excuse de faire encore une
citation mais celle là est très bien
c'est de jules renard il dit passer pour
un idiot
aux yeux d'un imbécile et une volupté de
fin gourmet enfin vous voyez c'est
dangereux parce que cette citation n'est
pas vu leurs larmes et courtes ninh nord
je vais entrer ce qu'ils ont pour un
gros con cette édition courtney wing
gagne quoi je parle quand je vois une
jolie femme je viens très con voilà une
bonne réponse
absence cheval cabré qui bondit vers
l'oubli cheval cabré que le vent cabré
cabre encore horizon blafard perle bleue
dans l'azur de ton sein soupire un
certain qui fend la nuit de glace
[Applaudissements]
michel polac bonsoir nous ça alors c'est
rare à la télé oui j'suis tricard
intérêt mais ça fait plaisir de vous
voir à votre place le samedi soir à
22h30 enfin un peu plus tard quand même
fait quoi en ce moment la théorie les
jeunes derrière ils sont tous savent
même pas ce que ça veut dire le rapport
avec 22h30 pas l'émission il était pas
vous connaissez polak vous en souvenez
de paulhac
c'est un cinéaste ouais c'est vrai il a
fait là il a fait la chute d'un corps
que d'un très beau film ses huit fils
louis film enfin la chute d'accord c'est
le méconnu
oui michel alors comment s'est pas vu
depuis longtemps à faire l'interview
check up vous m'en voudrez pas oui il
est prêt à tout dans cette émission
les gens étaient prêts à tous dans la
vôtre d'ailleurs faut mourir comme je
n'ai pas vu la vôtre ne regarde plus la
télé j'ai tricard à ce point là vous
n'avez plus droit diète les plus droits
de la regarder non plus ensuite je la
regardais mais j'avoue je je je m'en
désintéresse de plus en plus bas alors
interview check up c'est un peu pénible
enfin j'espère que vous y survivrait
maintenance et polak oui prénom le maire
michel oui toujours
et puis les bernard bernard des surnoms
non au pow pow pow il ya un mois voir
l'intimité elle vous appelle comment on
pousse à non bon poussines et non je
supporte pas quand on me donne des
surnoms de ce genre je m'en vais
améliorer la gaffe si l'on va vite les
auchan votre date de naissance
oh la la disquette 30 ouhlala ouais et
les complémentaires
la fête ça vous fait ben oui un puis
deux ans la retraite lieu de naissance
paris paris 16ème à choisir oui
ah bah ouais
s'il signe à salsigne a sonné beaucoup
souffert je ne signe astrologique bélier
vous y croyez à ce talent finalement un
petit peu ah oui principales maladies
auraient y en a un paquet non non moi ça
j'étais tout le temps malade mais je
sais soit viré soit malade samedi au
lieu d'aller chez le psychanalyste ou
fait dans une bonne petite mallette
alors il fait le ca somatisé vous avez
fait votre test quel test du sida du
sida winch est fait
oui je suis négatif ces cinq ans dans
les dents ça va les dons parce qu'on
commence à m'en remettre des fausses
mais ça se voit pas trop lent contraire
il a deux ou trois vous avez les cheveux
g sec froid sec plutôt les yeux comment
ça va ben les yeux par un peu d'allergie
le ça va puis j'ai des lunettes
myopes presbytes astigmate je suis prêt
suis très bien si ta gueule profession
des parents
hélas ce mon père était tout le monde
appelait ça directeur commercial compte
et importateurs de balle il a été
important il n'a pas été importateur il
est allé se faire de la banane en
afrique
hier j'ai une photo de lui et que son
casque colonial et s'épanouit répond t
il après la tempête
vous avez une enfance pauvre ou riche
bas jusqu en 39 une enfance riche et
après 39 une enfance popeux s'est mal
passé ça s'est très mal passé vous êtes
autodidacte diplômés allongé que mon bac
autodidacte par tout à fait vous avez
des problèmes d'adolescence rébellion
contre les parents à bah oui qu'est-ce
que je n'ai pas tellement voulu
continuer mes études et je suis parti
sur la route
c'était avant les beatniks mais c'est un
peu ça c'est aussi travaillé dans des
fermes j'ai travaillé dans des usines je
fais la pêche buvait plus je vieillis
plus je trouve qu'un bond à ses quelque
chose de fort bien mais le whisky tout
ça le champagne non combien de cuite par
semaine je ne me quitte pas avant ou
fumer
je ne fume plus la petite une pique
huawei célèbre qui vous avez vous avez
déjà pris du haschich 10,6 et j goûter
168 taux des prêts depuis ça m'a fait
beaucoup rire près et après j'ai trouvé
qu'un beaujolais c'était bien plus
agréable et ça me fait beaucoup plus
d'effet les c'est autre chose que karine
herry non vraiment j'ai horreur de tout
ce qui habille nos cerveaux les lsd tous
ces choses là se trouve terrible si si
j'ai un outil c'est mon cerveau alors
labit mecque des drogues non ou les
bouquins d'ormesson c'est donc tu
t'arrêtes vous avez eu deux épouses
j'ai deux épouses la première était une
iranienne racontez nous cette histoire
vous aviez fait trop vieux sans quoi
s'alarmer non mais c'était ma jeunesse
mais justement vous aviez 29 ans il en
avait 19 oui il y 13 coloris c'est ça
non mieux que moi jamais c'est très beau
vous avez pris le transsibérien pour la
retrouver
pas de consumer rien de transe iranien
je suis allé en train jusqu'à traverser
toute l'europe en train et puis ensuite
tout le caucase est là pour la retrouver
ou quinze jours de train étaient d'une
grande famille c'était là d'une dynastie
qui étaient là avant les avants les
pahlavi c'est ça c'est tous des cas déjà
une idée de la famille des capteurs et
vous avez été obligé de vous convertir à
l'islam chiite pour pouvoir l'épouser a
obligé c'est un grand mot c'est à dire
que je suis je suis pas les ponts marié
suis allé pour vivre une histoire
d'amour mais dans ces pays là c'est
difficile de vie sans être marié et puis
ça faisait tellement plaisir à la
famille que je leur ai dit je veux bien
alors j'ai vu l'ayatollah sont donc
c'était l'ont cloué comme il est au
courant
et alors j'ai discuté je n'aime pas
mentir je suis athée je ne crois pas en
dieu lunga série de câbles sur le shit
connelly remparts et 4
c'est là ok
chic voilà alors on a fait un petit
papier on a fait un petit mariage comme
ça folkloriques ont après vous être
mariée une deuxième fois avec une
journaliste de bugs ap dominique fostier
- loi et puis vous avez encore divorcé
après vous a vu cinq femmes
ouais c'est juste un mois ça vous a aidé
avec les femmes le vedettariat
j'espère que non parce que j'avais
l'illusion que ça ne m'était pas mais
c'est vrai que parfois on se demande
s'il n'avait pas effectivement c'est
triste si ça m'a aidé ça serait très
triste voulait pas voulait pas y prendre
ses affaires en panne on peut soit
vraiment on croit à séduire parce qu'on
se croit donc on croit qu'on peut
séduire mais si c'est parce qu'on est
célèbre
ça m'est arrivé au tout début de ma
célébrité comme on dit c'est que dans la
rue une femme souriait et je me disais
mon dieu j'ai un succès fou et l'ours il
était jolie je lui parlais à une femme
qui vous sourit mais à ce moment il
était complètement affolée et je
comprends mais qu'elle m'avait souris ni
comment est ce que m'avait reconnu à la
première fois que ça vous arrive ça fait
un choc est alors après je ne je n'ai
plus jamais graver plus après bonne
femme jackie qui est en face sur le
trottoir d'en face est elle va vers moi
et elle me sourit et moi je sors mon
stylo très content et elle me dit pardon
monsieur quelle heure est il
qui va mal classés toi alors est ce
temps c'est lui qui m'a demandé de venir
quand on regarde notre carrière on
remarque tout ce que vous avez fait
finalement se termine en querelle avec
vos partenaires en dispute avec la
direction en plainte contre la censure
ça fait partie de votre charme savant
juste très mauvais caractère et j'ai
toujours été indépendant sera face j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été indépendante
dans mon travail
on n'est pas indépendant par amour à
mille autres choses mais dans mon
travail j'ai toujours travaillé en
indépendant évidemment surtout d'un coup
on veut me donner un ordre je claque la
porte
enfin quand même je voudrais pas ériger
un peu en systèmes san ont annoncé mana
tueur c'est l'histoire de dents selon
elle ça le scorpion et la grenouille
parce qu en 54 parties au début c'est
vous qui avez imaginé le masque et la
plume grande émission s'il en est une où
jean d'ormesson participent déjà là mais
alors au bout d'un moment vous disputez
et françois-régis bastide
on n'ose pas disputer aussi on en est là
c'est parce qu'au bout de 17 ans
d'émission et un moment on en a eu un
peu assez de se regarder en chiens de
faïence que pouvait trouver enfin ça
fait d'autres choses bibliothèque pour
tous tout ça avoue fête post scriptum ça
se termine très mal je commençais par
une émission avoue plaignant des
conditions dans lesquelles le rtf vous
fait travailler et puis un jour poum
l'inceste
vous êtes viré voilà on fait une
émission avec louis malle est mort à
bien son lancer est ce parce qu'ils
avaient un film s'appelait le souffle au
coeur nous exposer mon métier oui on m'a
accusé d' apologie de l'insecte
l'inceste et des insectes en parlons
plat et j'ai claqué la porte
quand il eut droit de réponse n'est pas
arrêté d'avoir des problèmes avec la
avec la cncl ouais vous vous avez accusé
certains membres de la cncl faut dire
paul et pour les jeunes qui sont là que
c'était le csa de l'époque
vous avez accusé certains membres
d'avoir des connexions avec l'extrême
droite
oui oui vous avez été attaqué en
diffamation par pasqua lors de la
publication d'un bouquin qui s'appelait
des comme drogue
il a gagné à la forme de mazout et oui
vous avez des problèmes avec le pen vous
l'avait traîné lui vous a traité de
hyènes puantes et vous les traitez de
quoi sinon j'ai répondu si on se place à
ce niveau là je répondrais je ne sais
même plus à quoi aux bornes je ne sais
pas au plus tôt à bord notre édition se
place à ce niveau là et c'est lui qui se
place à ce niveau c'est moi dites moi à
tous les affronts dommages et intérêts
que vous avez perdu ça doit faire 10
francs dans toute votre carrière l'an ça
va coûter beaucoup plus cher alors un
procès ça coûte très cher et les frais
de justice ça monte
d'ailleurs je suis en procès que tf1
pour me faire rembourser les frais c'est
une partie vous avez souvent perdus dont
quand même non non pas si cela en deçà
attendant nous avons gagné d'étape
procès mais c'est très compliqué la
justice vous savez parce que si même si
vous avez votre bonne foi si on
reconnaît que vous êtes tout ce que vous
avez dit était vrai aussi été complet il
ya l'intention de nuit qui peut être
comme chez vous il fallait qu'on vous
dit quelque chose sur un certain temps
ça fait un mélange vous dites de jacques
médecin
ouais c'est un escroc on attention nuit
vous êtes condamné n'empêche que
maintenant c'est lui qui est condamné
mais non parce que ça ne change rien
condamné pour avoir dit ça par exemple
non non non le redis ça promet 200
réalité s'est débiné avant le procès ces
médecins sans frontières le meilleur le
meilleur moment de droit de réponse les
meilleurs moments chauds par y en a eu
beaucoup
il ya peut-être l'émission sur les
casinos avec monsieur fratoni mais je
peux pas dire un mot sur ce monsieur qui
arrive il est revenue mais si vous est
donné mais lui les revenus c'est ça
voilà c'est ça le monde me dit moi vous
n'avez pas été dépassé par les
évènements un moment et un droit de
réponse un peu grisé par tout ça c'est
dur de résister à la griserie c'est vrai
parce qu'à un moment on se prend pour le
président de la république tellement là
on a une espèce de pouvoir entre les
mains mais je crois pas avoir été
vraiment brisé
j'ai peut-être dérapé de temps en temps
on glisse one zahia d vous avez pensé un
moment que vous êtes compris pu vous
éliminer des médias annonceurs toujours
pensé que c'était du provisoire
puis j'ai toujours fait ce métier me
disant c'est provisoire peuvent perdre
aux drômois jamais causé sakho mon
métier
il ya des émissions en voisine ou
cousines aujourd'hui de droit de réponse
je peux pas juger les autres j'en sais
rien je ne crois pas parce que ce qui
faisait la particularité de notre
mission c'était des dossiers qu'on
préparé pendant des semaines qu'on avait
les pièces qu'on sortait quand quelqu'un
disait c'est pas vrai débat voilà la
preuve ça n'existe plus et c'est trop de
travail
vous avez dit dans le monde en 80 si
j'ai un besoin furieux de [ __ ] la
merde finalement vous pensez que ça vous
caractérisent c'est un compliment
oui c'est à dire que vous j'ai dû le
dire dans une circonstance particulière
mais j'aime pas du tout que l'ordre
règne et qu'on n'ait pas le droit de
mettre un peu de désordre alors la merde
c'est le désordre et le désordre c'est
la vie foutent la merde pour l'interview
c'est un peu comme le saut à l'élastique
pour d'autres 6 me sens pas tellement et
lots n'ont pas tous à cg l'image que
vous avez en tous les cas
mais non je vous ai dit pour les pour
les rigolos jardin marolleau j'allais
j'allais dire pour vous j'ai l'air d'un
intello bien sûr mais je me vole entier
oui j'étais arrivé en 81 87 sur sur tf1
vous étiez méfiant puis finalement il
est pas tellement de quoi ils vous
appeler mon vieil anar ce formidable ça
quand même que oui ça c'est des noces
qui ont duré quelques semaines jusqu'à
ce que vous consacrez une émission à
brigue
oui mais ça c'était la règle du jeu
quand il a été privatisée j'ai dit
j'accepte de rester sur une télé privée
à condition qu'on ait le droit de parler
non pas de la chaîne elle même c'est la
maison mais des affaires d'autres prier
terre et comme il y avait un
propriétaire principal
il fallait qu'on puisse parler des
innombrables d'affaires de bouygues il
avait dit vous aurez le droit le
dépendant et ben non ils fameux dessin
diaz avec devient sur le bruit c'était
le prétexte et les de merde là oui il y
avait une maison de maçon un pont de
masse ont une télé de merde mais il
faisait dire ça boue y faisait dire à
boeing c'était la tête de bruit qui
s'énervaient comme ça wauquiez licencié
pour faute grave n'ait touché combien
l'indemnité trajet lyon maison millions
maisons phénix 15 mois d'indemnités aux
logiques e vous avez vous lu à ce
moment-là rentrer à la 5 e vous avez
demandé le droit de critiquer robert
hersant be alors jean d'ormesson on peut
pas critiquer robert hersant quand on
travaille au figaro allemande est
absolument libre jeu contre moi même
j'ai écrit des articles qui n'était pas
vraiment aimable pour le béret ressent
dans son contre jour nabeul donc ça il
faut rendre hommage et ressent et on est
tout à fait libre
vous connaissez ya une nouvelle deux
heures de tchekhov qui s'appelle salle 6
1 où il ya comme ça l'illusion de la
liberté c'est un médecin qui dit fou
mais pourquoi vous vous souciez de
sortir de sortir la liberté dette
intérieure vous êtes libre de mon vieux
jusqu'au jour où le médecin prend pour
un fou et on le met avec le fou il ya
soit là il devient vraiment fou de ne
pas pouvoir sortir et je pense que vous
dites que vous êtes libre au figaro vous
êtes un type de situation de ce fou dans
la maison de fous comment il s'est fait
autant bon alors tout le monde tout le
monde est dans la même chute web tous
les noms on n'est pas si loin que ça 1 0
quand même en 89 vous choisissez m6 fait
libre échange est vite parti fâché je
suis parti fâché parce que m me suis dit
ils ont décidé tout d'un coup d'arrêtés
en plein mois de mai ce que font une
saison pour arrêter parce qu'ils avaient
décidé de venir ou chaîne de jeunes et
qui pensaient que la littérature c'était
pas pour les jeunes alors voilà c'est
après vous avez fait une émission avec
rap bernard monsieur frêche est très
fâché
olala vous appelez le mot pour le lire
sur france inter oui non il sait pas
très bien c'est un type qui avait appris
à présenter les infos sur un prompteur
il ne pouvait pas faire une émission
littéraire
oui je le pense toujours ouais
mais c'est pas de la jalousie je n'ai
pas envie de ça plane sur fr3 vous avez
tout fait un spécial racines ça s'est
mal terminée oui il y avait une émission
sur des sujets de cette année quand on
voit votre carrière comme ça c'est vrai
c'est pas un endroit vous êtes parti en
bons termes et que la vie avec ses vrais
sociable en un mot il shell paf
aujourd'hui moi ce que je ce qui me
réjouit ce qui m'a fait pleurer des
larmes de joie
c'est sur arte de voir pablo casals à
20h30 jouer du bach et ensuite une leçon
de musique alors les jeunes ne savent
peut-être pas qui est pablo casals parce
que c'était une émission filmé puis de
1954 par des américains diversit
berkeley qu'on n'avait pas trouvé le
moyen de diffuser 5954 sur le service
public
alors là moi j'applaudis arte et jeudi
les jeunes regarder de temps en temps
vous allez voir qu'on a de sacrées
bonnes heures 30
quels thèmes choisiriez vous de quoi
avez vous envie de parler
j'avoue maintenant que j'ai surtout
envie de parler de bouc peu et je dois
dire surtout de littérature étrangère je
préfère de pena jean d'ormesson mais
j'ai pas de passion pour l'homme en
charge en tête
et le sida n'ont pas très bien placé
pour faire des missions là dessus cela
dit c'est vrai que la transfusion
sanguine et monsieur garreta j'aurais
arrêté pour effet de montrer quelque
chose sur le sida prenez votre petit
téléviseur et regardez vous à venir si
c'est de l'info ou si c'est de l'intox
plus forts plus rapides plus lucrative
que les traditionnelles actions de wall
street voici le dernier placement sans
risque en vogue aux usa la spéculation
sur l'espérance de vie des malades du
sida en phase terminale la technique
racheter aux malades contre une grosse
somme d'argent
sa police d'assurance vie et attendre sa
mort pour toucher la totalité de la
prime d'assurance certains courtiers
vont même jusqu'à jouer les
intermédiaires en achetant pour revendre
un spéculateur l'assurance vie d'un
sidéens
c'est d'autant plus cher que la mort est
proche un viager nouvelle formule en
quelque sorte doigt quand j'ai quand
j'ai vu j'ai vu ça c'est que j'ai une
sorte évidemment de vol au coeur parce
que d'autres expressions étaient et
étions au bord du supportable à prendre
malades du sida en viager mais en même
temps concrètement c'est bien de ça dont
il s'agit dans un deuxième temps même si
on théorie tout le monde est d'accord
pour trouver ça immoral
en pratique les gens dit elle finalement
coûté six mois j'ai autour de moi
j'avais y avait quelqu'un qui était
vraiment dans un désarroi total puisque
puisque tu me dis que c'est légalement
possible
moi je serais prêt à le faire et oui en
france c'est possible dans le cadre de
l'assurance décès il suffit de changer
le nom du bénéficiaire et 10 mètres
celui de votre voisin qui vous aurait
proposé en échange d'une coquette somme
d'argent
mais cette opération ne peut se faire
que en dehors de la connaissance de la
compétition ce qui aura juste pour
information du souscripteur
ce changement de pouce bénéficier mais
qui n'aura pas en connaître le motif
mais pour l'essentiel les homosexuels
français voient dans l'achat des
assurances vie aux usa le problème de la
solitude des malades du sida
si les homosexuels qui sont en grande
partie touchée par le sida
avec d'autres structures pour vivre en
compagnie d'un autre homme par exemple
ou avait le moyen d'adopter des enfants
peut-être qu'ils ne qui ne serait pas
amenée à vendre ou à revendre leurs
assurances marchés spéculatifs sur la
mort s'indigne les adversaires de cette
pratique aux états unis en france il ya
fort à parier que cette initiative ne
passerait pas à la barrière du comité
d'éthique mais sait-on jamais j'ai des
malades du sida s de l'info est ce de la
taxe pendant que vous chercher chez vous
pendant que mes invités réfléchissent
ici qu'est ce que les coûts de corte
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'air très intello
comme ça mais détrompez vous je suis
moi-même intello j'ai chez moi des
livres 5 que je vais pas payer une
colorier évidemment j'avais une cassette
de desproges été fabuleuse et ça
s'appelle garder sa carence des sakharov
j'ai participé de manière dérangeait pas
bon non je manifeste toujours tout seul
gardez sakharov
c'est vrai quand on est plus de quatre
ans une bande de cons alors france a
fortiori -2 c'est l'idéal gardez
sakharov hyardet forrester mes idées
sont trop original pour susciter
l'adhésion des masses bêlante
ataviquement acquise au 1er suite et
transpirante et braillarde inhérentes à
la vulgarité du régime démocratique
imposée chez nous depuis deux siècles
par la canaillerie j
[Musique]
qui parmi vous qui êtes ici ce soir et
qui ne semblait globalement pas plus et
bt que le commun des électeurs qui
oseraient se levait publiquement comme
jose le faire moi-même pour exiger
l'extermination des mercières
les masques eu la scion des architectes
paysagistes le rétablissement de la
peine de mort en france
pour les chanteurs illettrés et
l'interdiction de stationner devant chez
moi
qui oserait monté au créneau comme on
dit pour manifester avec moi dans la
dignité pour le maintien en résidence
surveillée d'andreï sakharov
mais savez-vous - tir est sakharov vous
qui j'ai nié sur son sort par route et
une part coutume parce que c'est dans le
courant des idées reçues
attention faudrait pas vous tromper
sakharov ce n'est pas un doux rêveur
écorché que broie la main de fer d'un
état totalitaire adrets tout
judicieusement t'attacher ses coutumes
millénaire d'ordre et de discipline
c'est le papa de la bombe atomique
soviétique sa 40
c'est un considérable grandin qui a
passé le plus clair de son existence à
mettre au point la deuxième moitié du
programme d' anéantissement total de la
planète
c'est un dangereux maniaque ce type oui
vous allez me dire que son prix nobel
lui a coûté cher je sais mais vous savez
y est jamais très loin d'un char nobel à
tchernobyl
et puis venez pas me parler de la soi
disant non responsabilité du savant face
aux utilisations détournées de ses
découvertes
cela je rigole il ya autant de savants
innocents dans le monde qui avait deux
paysans persuadé d'habiter pas de lusine
olida dans les faubourgs de buchan
valdes 1900 albert einstein qui a
appliqué sa [ __ ] de théorie à
l'énergie rayonnante
il ne sent les époux curie qui auront
lieu de prendre sur leur temps de
sommeil pour pour se reproduire comme
font les uns des jo passer leurs nuits à
brand l'hôtel du rail gun pierre et
marie curie sont coupables et je peux le
prouver
parfaitement je viens de démêler un
écheveau de preuves contre eux et je
suis prêt à le crier bien où vivent les
chevaux avant les grilles
qui est encore assez naïf pour croire
aux jésuites type jérémiades des savants
atomistes non mais écoutez les joindre
les cuistres où vous savez ma chère si
j'avais pu me doutais qu'on utiliserait
mes travaux atomique à des fins
militaires qui je vous assure que
j'aurais fait de la broderie plutôt que
de la recherche disait robert
oppenheimer et que s'ils croyaient le
bougre sommes que l'énergie atomique
c'était seulement destinée à éclairer
les salles de bains le fait est que le 6
août 1945 à 6h du matin il est clair
dans les baignoires
à hiroshima au jus et ça on achète en
viager des malades du sida s de l'info
est de l'intox
jean d'ormesson à vous de répondre bien
sûr que c'est vrai
naturellement c'est de la fraude je n'ai
entendu l'info aussi michel javaux ici
tout le monde incroyable que c'est vrai
c'est un sujet qui nous a été envoyé par
monsieur stéphane tonnait de paris qui
gagne déjà 2000 francs puisque son sujet
a été tournée maintenant pour savoir
s'ils gagnent 1000 francs de plus pour
savoir s'il est arrivé à tromper michel
polac on va regarder
la réponse est bien c'est de l'info
puisque les l'assurance vie dont que
racheter pour vous les malades du sida
est proposé comme un placement par
départ des courtiers américains
on donne toute une série d'informations
très développée sur le fait que les
malades sont très solides religieusement
sélectionné que sont des gens qui n'ont
pas pour eux qui ont maximum pour deux
ans à vivre que d'autre part n'y a pas
de cure miracle en vue et que donc le
c'est un placement qui est béton
j'en avais dit que c'était la faute à un
commentaire sur ces pratiques pour le
stop aux minables simplement mais enfin
c'est tout à fait pour en amérique et ça
viendra chez nous la toile qui à moins
qu'une loi interdit ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire c'est que les mecs des
qui on peut faire du fric dollars sur
n'importe quoi on s'engouffre là dedans
c'est rond disneyland des séropos quoi
c'est dur michel winock jusque jeudi
c'est c'est incroyable et dégueulasse
donc c'est vrai et puis c'est
dégueulasse puis c'est vrai alors
monsieur tenait gagne 2000 francs il n'a
pas trompé
michel polac donc ils ne gagnent pas
3000 francs corti le score entraîne en
lui ce soir tu entraînes à lui jamais un
souffle enfants fragiles aux frontières
des cimes du brecko ou rose de légumes
quel est le scotch au sentier frileux à
égalité pas attendre trois candidats nos
trois intellectuels
un partout
j'accueille maintenant jean d'ormesson
vous savez c'est au rayon des toujours
chantal mackay et tétouan mais moi j'ai
un scoop sur leurs dossiers dorment à
100 oui il est fan de baffie ah bon il
adore parce que c'est ma fille qui
trouve sa fin sur tille suffit jamais
grossier n'ont pas bien profond même
mois ils adorent ça
il vous le dira pas il est vrai mais de
regarder le nom messi sera tu n'es pas
il ferait son d'ormesson chaud mais il
fera tient à nom comme ça ça se retient
seulement j'aurais peut-être dû me
retenir aussi non je pense chantal
ladesou alors
houle aussi quand même vous avez été un
intello très médiatique non parce que
finalement ils chose que je savais pas
du tout j'ai appris qu'ils avaient
participé aux grosses têtes c'est vrai
c'est absolument je crois pas c'était
amusant mais avant l'académie française
après aussi aulnoye oui absolument
vous avez fait beaucoup de télé quand
même non oui enfin vous avez fait
beaucoup journalisme si vous en faites
encore beaucoup et vous êtes un peu
laissé vous le regrettez si vous étiez
un peu happé par l'actualité quoi un peu
perdu un peu de temps par rapport à vos
activités d'écrivain non oui oui oui je
regrette un peu
vous connaissez la phrase de gide
j'appelle une journalisme ce qui sera
moins intéressant demain qu'aujourd'hui
c'est sa chance à oui c'est épatant
ouais ça je me répète ça souvent un oui
et je dois vous dire que paul morand se
jetaient toujours sur moi
ils avaient été très choqués par une
france qui avait dans un premier livre
et ils se jetaient sur moi dans surtout
pas de pornographie et surtout pas de
gens là qui sont alors que lui
évidemment faisait du journalisme mais
il aimait tellement il y aussi il a
écrit des phrases très pornographie
politiquement absolument l'équipe france
la douche c'est non
il a écrit aussi je déteste écrire mais
j'adore avoir écrit ce vrai ouais l'a
dit dans ma fille alors si mal alors
qu'elle est dernier parmi nous qui a
fait pivot c'est moi le dernier café
philo aux délégués alors y'a pas photo
j'ai bien torché sur son cou la
spécialité
bien avant qu un rapport datant
maintenant vous le voyez c'est ce que je
lui ai dit ça leur est difficile voire
prêt mais attention par hasard je sais
que j'ai un grand désavantage à la télé
c'est que je vous ai vu que pivot a pris
ma fille papa petrov n'est pour bouillon
oui il a fait vivre quand même il a fait
bouillir auprès de dégueulasse à l'étang
vous avez dit je méprise les honneurs
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai cueilli au
passage oui parce que la seule façon de
vraiment les mépriser ces d avoir une
chance on est toujours un peu suspect
placé pour répondre à ma fille qui aime
les causes de la gueule dire monsieur
récitation de l'excitation c'est
l'horrible passion d'envié ce qu'on est
pris ouais j'ai envie de tonnes et
variées vous dira ce qui s'est vu qu'ils
s'aiment luis mariano
j'ai connu toutes les formes de
déchéance y compris le succès de qui
ardisson n'a s'y rend
ouais
[Applaudissements]
il y à 2 g dans l'existence réussir sa
vie et l'a ratée c'est qu'ils visitent
en transférant et moi la hausse car
wayne hall a eu quand même tant va la
cruche à l'eau
en fait pourquoi vous avez passé autant
de temps comme ça essayer d'acquérir le
pouvoir au jeu ça mais c'est là qu'ils
n'ont toutefois jamais ce que je peux me
reprocher est ce qu'on peut me reprocher
c'est d'avoir essayé d'acquérir une
certaine notoriété
et si vous voulez me faire dire ce que
je regrette c'est ça j'ai sûrement eu
envie et je trouve ça aujourd'hui tout à
fait maîtrisable d'être connu j'ai
sûrement aimé ça ça j'ai aimé ça je n'ai
jamais aimé pouvoir jamais voulu avoir
le pouvoir
j'ai toujours trouvé le pouvoir tout à
fait médiocre et cambio j'ai le figaro
pendant un moment ce n'est pas le
pouvoir ça
écoutez franchement d'abord oui d'abord
c'est le pouvoir mais d'abord je n'ai
jamais cherché on me l'a offert
évidemment je ne vais pas écartée il
faut dire que dès que j'ai pu me tirer
je me suis tiré et mousses et c'était
très tentant c'était très amusant il
faut pas cracher dessus vance un beau
temps chaud vous avez perdu beaucoup de
temps les mentalités aussi non pour 3 1
je me souviens d'un article vous disiez
je fais plus de dîners en ville cette
année j'en ai fait quatre et ont été le
19 janvier katleen erna merci si c'est
vrai parce que maintenant les gens
disent ah on vous voit partout à jouer
on avait vu l'endroit est finalement
très très très peu je sors très peu les
femmes nous ont fait perdre du temps
aussi
on pensait perdre du temps et montanes
et du leur et devront subir récents il y
à l'amour il ya les livres il y à rien
cette équipe
mon internat pour que les trucs pour
parler des femmes c'est pas le mieux
placé montherlant quand même nom mais il
en parle très bien et je trouve que ce
tracé très très bien et vous avez dit si
j'avais été une femme j'aurais mener les
hommes en bourrique
c'est quoi vous regrettez de favorite
est une garce non c'est parce que je
pense que j'ai
c'est parce que je pense que je pense
que l'un des traits quelques jeux que
j'en garde chez moi c'est de ce désir de
plaire j'ai sûrement un diseur de plaine
que comme mais vous plaisir assuré nous
allons regarder un film est plein de
points du toit ont envoyé sa peine je
vais essayer de faire tout ce que je
pouvoir pour le cssa va rater pas le cas
contraire argent pour séduire alors
alors je pense que si j'avais été une
femme sa mort est formidablement amusé
de faire marcher si on les dit le
mariage enfin en prenant les précautions
oratoires de vie de votre femme bien sûr
le maillage est quelque chose
d'abominable et la révolution française
avait bien fait de de bannir les veut
perpétuer la révolution a banni les
voeux par pq elle est en effet le
mariage et le dernier voeux perpétuels
et son sable minable je mets ma femme
tout à fait en dehors qui a eu la bonté
de me supporter pendant si longtemps et
qui était trop de horn qu'il faut la
mettre
mais le mariage sauf ça je trouve ça une
épreuve redoutable où ça veut c'est tout
à fait clair parce que le mariage il y a
chantant on se mariait déjà un peu vieux
avec des jeunes femmes très jeunes
et puis qu'est ce qu'on faisait au
mouret ouais mais l'idée de passer sympa
oui c'est ça c'est maintenant vie trop
vieux pour ça maintenant on se marie à
18 ans et on vit jusqu'à 90 ans
et pour vous êtes entre attendait
attendions enfin franchement ressortent
chez lattès donc trois romans vais
publier qui ressorte dans le même temps
le volume c'est combien de pages on sent
63 ou 65 mis en doute quelque chose
comme du chantage
le vent du soir comme les autres on s'en
fout et le bonheur à san miniato le
monde histoire des gens on dirait qu'ils
lâchent une quête à la seule vue par les
deux de ses trois romans il y avait quoi
que ça un feuilleton planétaire où le je
dirais que c'est un peu c'est ta faute
oui c'est un roman c'est un roman
feuilleton d'un roman feuilleton qui au
lieu de se passer ça à paris se passe
dans le monde entier vous savez ce que
ce qui s'est passé depuis depuis 100 ans
et que on se déplace une des choses qui
se fait c'est pour deux places et une
des choses qui m'amusent et dans ce
livre c'était de faire un roman qui se
passe en chine au brésil en amérique
pologne enfin partout et quand on se
balade un peu partout où je vais ensuite
à un feuilleton qui se passe partout et
c'est une des histoires d'amour d'un
feuilleton quoi alors il ya quatre
soeurs et un frère on va essayer de le
raconter parce que l'on annonce de
l'histoire de quatre soeurs et deux
frères et j'ai toujours été fascinée non
seulement parlent l'unification du monde
mais par les histoires de seul j'aime
beaucoup les soeurs je trouve que c'est
très joli les histoires de soeur c'est
toujours amusant parce que il ya une
rivalité entre elles d'émulation elles
sont semblables sont différentes
il ya dans l'histoire plein d'histoires
deux soeurs très amusante
il ya eu et fait un effort d'un film
contre hitler churchill c'est un livre
on croise les grands de ce monde enfin
c'est alors ce qui se passe les spas
dans un roman c'est que contrairement à
ce qu'on croit contrairement à ce que
croient bassil qui n'est plus là je peux
l'attaqué puisqu'il est plus là c'est
que dans un roman
ça ne compte que bravo dans un roman en
lançant comme ça
et les barbares
les barbares sont aux portes de la ville
dans un roman ça ne consiste pas à
inventer des choses extraordinaires et
il faut plutôt diminuer les choses de la
vie pour essayer de faire des choses
qu'ils soient mois semble au risque de
consacrer moins de temps encore avec les
tiers at-il relance voulu faire ça la
jeune homme
moins de temps à l'écriture vous êtes
engagé donc aux produits brevetés nick
l'année dernière est ce que vous
engageriez pour la somalie écoutez bien
sûr il ya des causes innombrables pour
lesquelles il faut se battre évidemment
longue à dubrovnik parce que c'est plus
beau graphiquement c'est vrai qu'on me
l'a reproché d'ailleurs double revenu
que ça m'a un peu bousculé par semaine
parce que c'est une très belle ville et
que si versailles ou venise ou chartres
était menacé ça vous et ce sans frais de
choses mais naturellement les gens qui
désirent un petit peu souffert amoureux
amoureux il ya ça aussi mais évidemment
les gens qui se font tuer à osijek coup
a vu que var ou à sarajevo qui est moins
beau que de nouveaux revenus que c'est
exactement la même chose
et évidemment il ya il ya quarante
courses dans le monde où auquel on
pourrait s consacré il ya un côté
quelquefois un peu ridicule il ya un
côté génocide et tourisme va fois les
parts ou se battre mais je m'en
construction salle et là on fait ce
qu'on peut
je montrais prenez votre petit
téléviseur vous aussi et regardez vous
allez me dire si ces deux là font ou si
c'est de l'intox
plus d'un million et demi de personnes
sont déjà mortes en somalie soit le
quart de la population
le pays est déchiré par la guerre civile
affamée par la sécheresse bernard
kouchner le ministre de l'action
humanitaire en visite sur place cet été
s'est indigné et a lancé un appel au
secours et à l'aide d'urgence
[Musique]
le docteur pierre malézieux député ps du
val-d'oise accompagné le ministre lors
de ce voyage dans les prochains jours il
va présenter devant l'assemblée
une mesure d' aide exceptionnelle à la
somalie prélever 2 % sur les recettes
des ventes d'aliments pour chiens et
chats
la taxe sera intégralement reversée à la
somalie la situation que nous avons
trouvée était pire que celle qui est
décrite à la télévision dans les
portages
c'est une population qui est en voie
d'extinction la famille est terrible et
environ 1500 à 2000 personnes par jour
pour gagner
80% d'entre nous ne pouvons laisser
cette population nous devons faire
quelque chose
les français dépensent chaque année 20
milliards de francs pour nourrir leurs
animaux de compagnie prélever une taxe
de 2% sur cette somme rapporterait 400
millions de francs en un an
le choix de taxer les aliments pour
animaux n'est pas anodin ces produits
sont déjà considérés comme produits de
luxe si bien que les professionnels
s'insurger contre ce nouvel impôt ne
vois pas pourquoi on va taxer comme par
hasard les aliments pour chiens il va
pas taxer par exemple les fabricants de
cosmétiques les fabricants d'armement
qui cause autant de dégâts si non plus
je pense que les animaux en france
en revanche les maîtres réputés pour
leur générosité sont plutôt séduits par
la proposition du député
quand on a des animaux va on aime les
bêtes on aime le monde normal d'aider
les autres par ce biais là j'ai un chien
maintenant tout l'argent qu'ils vont
prélever est-ce que ça va aller là-bas
c'est autre chose
pour être efficace la taxe doit être
limitée dans le temps cette opération
est donc ponctuelle
afin de préserver son caractère
exceptionnel taxe sur les aliments pour
chiens et chats pour nourrir les
somaliens s de l'afo s de la taxe je
vous le demande
pendant que vous réfléchissez chez vous
pendant que mais habité réfléchissent
ici qu'est ce que les coûts de corte
vous immoler mon âme endormi disparu
l'essence d'un soleil
[Applaudissements]
moi
un naufrage leur de marbre ou vibre un
espoir fou ruban après abyssal furie
janis ans furieux qui ses racines
arraché quel blaireau ce navire à bord
et céleste équinoxe et quelques crises
encore mortels trépas est à vue le voeu
brûlante rougis mon coeur a quand même
jamais foudroyé fait bien mieux sur les
aliments pour chiens et chats pour
nourrir les somaliens s de l'info est de
l'intox
michel bas étant donné que les députés
veulent toujours qu'on allège les impôts
ou qui n'ose jamais proposé des taxes je
dirais que c'est de l'intox uniquement
vu la mentalité des députés français moi
j'espère que ces deux-là faux j'espère
vraiment pour une fois qu'ils fassent
quelque chose et qui taxe les chiens
chats et les chalets whiskas des cop a
dit j'espère vraiment que c'est de
l'info je suis pas sûr et j'espère genre
je crois que c'est vrai ouais je croirai
que c'est vrai c'est un sujet qui nous a
été envoyé par madame nicole amsalem de
nice qui gagne déjà 2000 francs puisque
son sujet a été tournée maintenant pour
savoir si elle a trompé jean d'ormesson
on va regarder la réponse eh bien non
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas ma
maison je ne fais que passer devant
comme un simple citoyen je ne suis pas
député mais si j'avais été député c'est
quelque chose que j'aurais aimé faire
pour les somaliens
comme l'avait dit
elle est trop la psychologie des députés
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est trop la
nature humaine
toi tu t'es trompé oui j'ai dit j'espère
j'espère oui mais c'est vraiment dommage
bon peut-être cette émission le projet
final nous avons posé quand vous avez
été trompés dans madame amsalem gagne
3000 francs au lieu de 2000 et corti on
regarde le score qu'elle est le score le
polonais même devant le noble et le
russe polak 2 bercoff et monsieur
d'ormesson et j'accueille vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu peux envers kof j'espère que vous
n'êtes pas aussi difficile à maquiller
que vous est difficile à comprendre
moi j'ai compris les to business vous
parlez tous vos spécialistes en tout
vous avez un avis sur tout et puis vous
êtes assez balèze dans le reste aussi
moi j'y comprends rien du tout et voyez
entente maquilleuse moi si je m'écoutais
je vous maquille irait en intello
[ __ ] gourou clown écolo j'ai
oublié quelque chose non non oui oui
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
kenza aurait dit moi à vous a oublié
voyageurs un voyageur si oui vous des
amoureux amoureux oui faites quelque
chose après l'émission baffin alors je
vais temps d'agir
ma fille d'alors mais elle te réveiller
ma fille va dormir baffie c'est la
démangeaison intrinsèque au coeur du
confort pour jour
voilà et de tous les noms message vous
pensé la même chose
après d une expression aussi à idées
gagnantes je ne peux plus rien dire de
reste sans voix
laurent baffie le berrichon
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
serrurier obama lé hula le quai gillet
ou vos jolies brebis parce que dans les
clauses minute une pénalité la veux pas
c'est bon tous les 15 ans ont gardé la
main je livrais j'arrive tout de suite
bon je livrais vite parce qu'après je
peux faire lourder mois ces housses et
lars boom regarder d'abord il faut que
je lis rohmer de regarder ce qu'on me
fait faire aussi belle et des mois
maintenant mais non mais je demande un
renseignement et puis vous soyez pas
grossir ses ratés sur monsieur voilà
tous les mois
[Musique]
attention monsieur soit vous n'êtes pas
d'erika non plus bon alors je veux dire
oh bordel merde et je me tiens loin des
labos mais des monsieur vous me dites
oui ça se lâcheront fait virer la tenue
à rabat et si on mettait la merde de
chien comme j'ai pas pris merguez et on
va la mettre d'accord allez on va mettre
la main dans la main pour l'améliorer
mais on s'en fout on est jeune regardez
up pardon à donner aux prairies je me
fasse agresser présentable ou pas
monsieur bon ça va faire la blague
vous croyez que c'est pas bien vous en
foutez non c'est pas vous c'est moi
non parce que si ça fait trop on la met
pas on dirait une merguez ou pas on
dirait quoi tout ce que vous voulez mais
pas à quoi je la retire alors allez-y
alesi aussi aller si monsieur c'est vous
qui m'avez donné l'idée me suis rendu
tout et on voit la mauvaise foi voilà
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça un
bien non mais c'est pas la cerise sur le
gâteau au niveau de la présentation
presse a de la gueule quand même hein ça
fait la blague ou pas bon ben la merde
de chien au caire au niveau de la déco
c'est pas superbe sas et présentable
maintenant hein c'est pas pour vous
messieurs
j'étais à l'essai et puis j'ai tout fait
tomber un oui soyez pas que je pourrais
trouver du travail
non bien logement chez vous ça va pas
être possible si j'ai des amis qui
aurait un matelas rien du tout quoi 5
francs la part laissez vous tenter c'est
la dernière
allez septembre la ola c'est pas mal
aulas
tous les invités
c'est pas la peine d'en rajouter ouais
c'est une royale les gens à pizza
d'ormesson ça n'a pas fait rire je vais
te dire aux filles la veille ils
demandent pas l'épisode par téléphone
alors toi aussi tu as 20 telle autre
très médiatique
ouais je sais pas ce que ça veut dire tu
sais très médiatique ça veut dire ah tu
fais les missions de journée quatre
jours par semaine et absolu sur france 3
tout à fait qu'ils s'appellent français
si vous parlez exacte et tu vas en
province mais je fais plus parler les
autres que je parle moi mais oui je
donne la parole aux récepteurs plutôt qu
aux émetteurs c'est sacrément je fais
parler des gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude
de la parole et j'aime bien en fait
qu'on charge ne peut que ce soit pas
toujours les mêmes qui parlent sans
démagogie du tout je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont des choses à
dire aussi au moins aussi intéressante
que les gens qui sont les professionnels
de la parole ce sont les gens qui va qui
parle c'est dire qu'en général ça vous
frappez c'est que quand tu vois dans les
journaux tu vas le représentant machin
leader syndical le représentant de hicks
est alors les infirmières les routiers
les agriculteurs tu les vois jamais on
les voit en train de flamber des de la
viande en train de [ __ ] et les camions
ou tu vois en embouteillages et en fait
tu as 30 secondes et après sa vie ce
type ces problèmes tout ça rien ouais
ben moi j'ai envie qu'ils parlent un peu
plus c'est pour ça que tu fais quoi les
les cahiers de doléances finalement
norway absolument un tiers état c'est ça
c'est le tiers état partie publie chez
albin michel à bouquin qui s'appelle
lettre ouverte à ceux qui ne sont rien
qui veulent être tout ça aussi c'est
très proche d'eux des cahiers de
doléances face à la même épreuve et oui
tout à fait c'est assez apple
prolongement mais en réfection le livret
permet la réflexion ce que ne permet pas
l'image enfin de la même façon en gros
c'est quoi c'est que j'ai dit que il ya
une implosion
c'est à dire qu'il ya plus les chefs ne
sont plus suivis on l'a bien vu avec du
sens de maastricht où que ce soit des
chefs syndicaux politiques religieux ou
autre mais médiatique même médiatique et
ce qui est intéressant c'est où va et ce
que je dis c'est que si on commence pas
considérer que les gens ce qui compte
c'est la liberté
ce qui compte c'est de ne pas se laisser
enfermer dans des étiquettes ethnique
nationaliste raciale ou autre on est
foutu c'est bosnie à sarajevo partout
peu et c'est ça qu'il faut arrêter et la
bosnie à sarajevo n est pas seulement
dehors quand on dit qu'il faut aider les
autres c'est vrai mais aussi dans nos
têtes vous faire très très gafas à côté
attention lui il est comme ça à l'entrée
comme
ça c'est insupportable c'est ça qu'il
faut casser en tout cas essayer c'est
très écologiste sinon c'est pas écologie
c'est que ce que je dis en gros c'est
que ce qu'on appelait le communisme et
qui n'a jamais été autre chose qu'un
capitalisme d'état s'est cassé la gueule
et c'est bien le capitalisme archaïques
ce qui laisser faire et laisser aller on
voit très bien résultat que ça donne
et peut-être que le capital ils ont
corrigé par l'écologie se comprendre une
chose c'est que quand on dit il faut
aider vos idées tant que les gens ont de
moi j'ai mon truc les autres je m'en
fous en fait c'est pas la morale qui va
faire je le jour où tu as une couche
d'ozone qui craque et que c'est bon pour
les riches pour les peaux pour les
gauche ou la droite
ouais cardia de tchernobyl qui risquent
de craquer ils capturent des du
nucléaire qui sort et le nucléaire il va
peut faire attention entre les nantis
il pense que plus ça sera pire mieux ce
sera grand non je pense qu'il faudra
faire de plus en plus l'attention parce
qu'il ya une globalité
tu consultes analyse mme écologique
c'est le poste socialiste je pense en
tout cas que l'écho capitalisme est
quelque chose qui remplacera le
socialiste qui d'ailleurs qu'on n'a
jamais vus bien dire il prend son virage
le pervers coeur j'ai jamais été
socialiste hoorens marxien du ter je dis
simplement qu'il faut arrêter de penser
que les solutions viennent tout d'en
haut mais page 54 tu dirais qu'il avait
54 un service vaut dit philosophe parce
que je pense que quelquefois la
consommation qu'on a beaucoup qu'on a
beaucoup attaqué la marchandise les
tacles en dix ans elle a l'art était
déjà l'un des vrais les situationnistes
c'était très important
cela dit la marchandise tu crois que
l'esclavagé a été aboli pourquoi par
souci humanitaire mondiale à laon peu
plus des esclaves pas du tout parce que
les et cela pouvait devenir des
consommateurs
quand ford a décidé de bien payer les
ouvriers passion des ouvriers il faut
qu'on les paye bien parce qu'ils vont
acheter le produit
il faut comprendre ça et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la morale et ben c'est pas mal
mais je préfère que le mec soit
consommateur qu'esclave tu dis qu'il
faut plus comprendre dans la morale de
gauche
l'allégeance pour les pédophiles les
assassins d'enfants etc
non je dis simplement que au nom de la
différence il faut pas accepter
n'importe quoi je veux dire qu'on l'à
beaucoup beaucoup prôné le respect des
cultures
moi je dis quand on coupe le clitoris
des petites filles au nom du respect
culturel je dis non quand on fait tout
ce qui est inutile tout ce qu'ils
propret aux primes au nom de respect
culturel je dis non et je dis simplement
que effectivement un pédophile a mais
qu'il manipule les tirs sont tous les
petites filles
pour moi c'est de la merde et que ça
doit être condamné quelle que soit la
chose ya une morale mais la morale c'est
pas une morale judéo-chrétienne
c'est simplement des règles que des gens
se sont battus pendant un siècle pour
établir qu'il n'y a pas à avoir honte de
ses règles et à pas à les renier c'est
tout
[Applaudissements]
et
une pensée qui en france des portes
ouvertes un peu oui mais il faut les
enfoncer des portes ouvertes parce que
souvent beaucoup de gens elles sont
encore fermés tu as encore procuré les
femmes avec tout ça on devrait pas ce
que tu dis que dans le sexe on est
rentré on sent un autre bouquin qui s'en
tirent pas longtemps oui on est rentré
dans le règne de l'ersatz avec le
minitel avec moi cinéma le film porno et
oui mais il ya il faut dire la danse
aussi l'histoire du parti d'en jouer oui
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya comme tu sort
un bouquin tous les deux mois quand on
fait un vite on en profite pour parler
de tout ce que je voulais dire c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'à une normalisation
de la société nos plus gros de la
religion parce que ça marche plus mais
au nom de l'hygiène peut aller coûte
qu'est ce qu'on dit on il ne sortait pas
il ya des loupes dehors qui voudrait
attaquer ne mangez pas il ya de la
pollution ne baiser pas et un sida ouais
je fumais pas c'est les poumons qu'elle
ne connaît pas la télé voilà notre leçon
de buvait pas celle actuelle résultats
et consorts l'impression que l'idéal
d'un certain nombre de gens et c'est
quoi ces voix là ce type c'est la
société
tu vois on s'enferme ouais on a hâte est
l'antithèse prothèse alors enfin son fax
voilà sa machine à communiquer aux
relations téléphone fait et puis on est
contente donc on est plus dans les
solitaires plus on est entouré de
machines à kobe il communique rien du
tout c'est vrai les schistes pour toi ça
assez complètement c'est le nouvel ordre
moral au nom de ligier un peu tu crois
qu'il vaut mieux dans ses champs sur un
champ de mines soit complètement ouais
comme lui par exemple
que je les avais qu il faut être informé
ouais quand nous informe la partie
moment les adultes qu'on lui foute la
paix ouais je sais ce que c'est c'est
qu'en fait on veut on fait une société
sous préservatif toute la société peut
pas seulement le sexe la société
préservatif attention ne prenez plus
aucun risque et le problème c'est qu'on
a des écrivains sans risque on a des des
chercheurs sans risque on a des des
intellectuels sans risque et c'est ça
qu'il faut merde et c'est ça dont on
souffre on a des livres sans vis honda
les livres sont responsables j'ai un
sujet pour vous la gent je remarque un
truck series fait c'est qu'ils sont tous
venus avec un livre à vendre et moi je
n'avais rien à vendre
c'était pareil c'est pas bon parce qu'il
n'a pas fait de bouquins lui c'est pas
ça s'écrit à 22h30 à la télévision il
est à sa place
sujet pour jean d'ormesson ce sujet de
cléopâtre regardez vous aime dire si
c'est de l'info ou si cette attaque
cléopâtre s'était allié à césar puis à
antoine pour tenter de redonner à
l'egypte sa grandeur passée mais elle
n'avait pas su séduire octobre et
préféra la mort à l'humiliation momifié
son corps enfouis dans les sables
d'alexandrie traversa les siècles mais
en 1860 alors que l'égyptologie
passionne occident un aventurier
découvre une tombe et vient troubler
ainsi le repos éternel de la grande
reine d'égypte un consul italien qui
travaille en egypte trouve un lot de
momies parmi lesquelles celles de la
grande cléopâtre il en fait don à la
france est immédiatement sur l'ordre de
napoléon iii
la momie est exposé au musée du louvre
[Musique]
la momie est exposée une dizaine
d'années et puis survient la guerre de
70 les conservateurs ont peur que la
momie tombe aux mains des prussiens
alors une nuit en catimini
il traverse le jardin du palais royal
avec la momie et la dépose à la
bibliothèque nationale le 3 mai 1870 les
prussiens sont aux portes de paris
monsieur mortreuil secrétaire général de
la bibliothèque nationale enregistre
alors l'arrivée de trois momies par
précaution il n'inscrit pas le nom de
cléopâtre dans le livre d'inventaire et
ce qui s'est passé ensuite non plus
pendant la gamme 77 et trois momies donc
ont été descendus dans les caves de la
bibliothèque nationale pour les
sauvegarder ainsi que d'autres durent
être d'autres objets pour les
sauvegardes et des bombardements
prussiens et l'année suivante
pendant la commune donc la commune a
investi la bibliothèque nationale et le
commandant de la garde
descendant un jour dans les caves a vu
ses mots me disais plus tôt senti du
reste puisqu'elle commencé à se
décomposer en raison de l'humidité qui
régnait dans cette cave et donc il a il
en a ordonné l'enterrement dans le
jardin d'hygiène
aujourd'hui personne ne sait où dans le
jardin vivienne repose la momie de
cléopâtre aucune fuite n'a jamais été
entreprise car cent vingt ans après que
resterait-il du dernier pharaon d'égypte
cléopâtre enterrés dans les jardins de
la ville du kef nationale s de l'info et
l'intox
je vous le demande pendant que vous vous
le demandez aussi que mes trois invités
se le demande ici qu'est ce que les
coûts de cortaillod mes frères pour
mettre un petit peu de rythme dans cette
émission des filles qui n'ont pas que la
peau sur les os qui ne manque ni de sel
ni de pépé salt n pepa expression
[Musique]
il
la vie
m
cup
je sais
non
ok
[Musique]
je
enterrés dans les jardins de la
bibliothèque nationale s de l'info s de
l'intox
michel polac j'aurais préféré répondre
après d'ormesson pas sûr qu'il le sait
moi je dis que c'est de l'intox parce
qu'à mon avis tu es aux pattes états
unis la mort qu'elle a eues on n'a pa
modou lô n'a pas modifié la pauvre genre
je crois que c'est de l'intox
ouais ouais je crois que je crois que
c'est de la roya clown et qu'on a gardé
encore et encore
c'est un sujet qui nous a été envoyé par
monsieur gilles fournel de bordeaux qui
viennent de 1000 francs puisque la
tournée son sujet et pour savoir si je
vais rajouter mille francs pour savoir
s'il est arrivé à tromper andré bercoff
on écoute la réponse non ce n'est pas la
momie de cléopâtre pour la simple raison
qu on n'a jamais retrouvé la momie de
cléopâtre j'ajoute que si jamais cette
momie avait été exposée au louvre les
inventaires on aurait conservé la trace
ce qui n'est pas le tas entre nous soit
dit
c'est aussi bien laissons la place à
l'imagination c'est une rumeur qui est
qui est né au 19e siècle qui sans
fondement real nous avons bien eu
effectivement des momies trois momies
dont on connaît les noms et qui sont
toutes des momies masculine donc ne
venez pas chercher la momie ici mais en
revanche vous pouvez venir voir l'image
de pau retraités aux pattes sur des
monnaies qui sont elles bien conserver
ici
je trompais des invités intello sur un
sujet pareil gens vous étiez au courant
de la rumeur dont je pensais que si je
suis vraiment que par travail qui est
enterré à paris on l'aurait su boeing
quand même d'une autre il ya une rumeur
quand même un sur leur cléopâtre une
rumeur 19e siècle oui enfin je suis pas
arrivé à vous à vous tromper monsieur
fournol ne gagne que 2000 francs et
corti tu nous as le score c'est le noble
reste à une tête de michel polac qui
remporte le match ce soir
bravo
avec 1,7 dans les bras ça me rappelle
dali quand je l'interviewais il avait
une cave à vin peut pas dans la liste
oui c'est un peu l'esprit effectivement
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir
suivis et rester avec nous parce que
maintenant je vais confesser et oui je
vais confessé michel polac
[Musique]
michel tu t'es déjà confessé jamais quel
effet cette fait ou pas grand chose
parce que je me confesse à moi même dit
favorable à l'euthanasie
tout à fait et je souhaite vivement pour
moi même donc je suis tout le temps
malade ça me dit le jour vraiment il le
faudra sans hésiter pour les autres ça
les regarde tu n'es pas contre le
suicide
pas du tout c'est même une porte de
sortie très honorable et je trouve que
ça donne un sentiment de liberté quand
vraiment quelque chose devient
insoutenable il faut pouvoir se dire il
vaut mieux le suicide que le déshonneur
pour parler avec des grands mots tu as
souvent parler du suicide comme une arme
contre la compromission
oui oui oui je crois que ne pas avoir
peur de la mort du suicide est une façon
de résister à la peur à l'humiliation à
tout ce qu'on peut vous proposer comme
comme corruption aussi inutile de
demander si tu est favorable à la peine
de mort eh ben je vais te surprendre jeu
je suis plutôt favorable à la peine de
mort pour une raison très simple c'est
que la prison me paraît beaucoup plus
effrayante de la mort s'ils ont deux
j'avais le choix pour moi même je
préférerais qu'on fiche une balle dans
la tête que de m'enfermer à vie dans une
prison je crois en dieu
non je crois dans le tout dans le cosmos
dans quelque chose qui rayonne mais dieu
comme une personne qui surveillerait les
actes et qui se pencherait sur mon sort
alors là ça me fait un peu sourire tu as
dit de toi que tu étais un athée
mystique ça veut dire quoi ça c'est ça
c'est que je suis un peu panthéiste que
je crois que l'univers tout entier
quelque chose qui peut être considéré
comme à la fois exaltant et terrifiante
c'était l'heure est à la pointe ciel et
l'enfer mais il n'ya pas que l'enfer il
ya le ciel
sam exalte tu crois au diable je
commence à me poser la question parce
qu'en vieillissant je vois tellement se
renouveler les mêmes erreurs que je me
dis qu'il ya une fatalité dans l'homme
et que ça pourrait s'appeler le diable
mais en fait c'est un un bout de
marionnette des guignols ne regrette pas
d'avoir perdu tout ce temps à faire de
la presse de la télé pas avoir et
écrivain a su ça je le regrette
certainement mais je veux dire que là
aussi on a sonné un destin je pense que
c'est un regret idiot parce que j'étais
certainement fait pour faire ce métier
et que je les fais longtemps à regret en
me disant mais tu perds ton temps puis
maintenant je me dis après tout je
continue très secrètement à faire mon
métier d'écrivain
donc après tout l'équilibré est rétabli
à 25 ans quand tu as publié la vie
incertaine chez gallimard avec un
certain succès j'étais posé la question
en mai gizo les pour écrire à mais tout
à fait mais je n'arrêtais pas de le
faire je l' ai fait ma vie j'ai fui en
permanence pour ça que ça m'arrangeait
vient de claquer la porte des fiches à
la porte c'était une occasion pour moi
d'aller écrire et il m'est arrivé passé
des mois tout seul dans la montagne pour
écrire le résultat n'était pas toujours
à la hauteur de l'effort que ce soit
c'est la télé ça bouffe l'âme
tout à fait je crois que c'est vraiment
des métiers les plus dangereux qu'on
puisse faire pour son intégrité pour son
équilibre pour la sagesse qu'on te
recherche que pour soi même ça ne manque
pas du tout pas du tout je crois que je
crois vraiment que c'est une sorte de
drogue et qui est de savoir s'en passer
indispensable brûlot sélect où finit là
qu'ils ont est accouchent en un mot ou
murphy cheval fourbu un temps fourbu
pourtant fourbus de moi planète envier
planète à bord et villages engloutis
sous un flot impétueux remous du
désordre à l'infini un fameux tueur pour
toi
blais mais la passion recul
et puis recule encore et l'ombre du
toujours plane sur ce prêt au portique
infernal où surgir à l'effroi toro
maudit dont fument les naseaux
fleurs embaumé d'un farfan orientale
rebeix désagréger pour mieux la pluie
mais encore tombe l'orage tombe et
tombera pourtant car d'escalier furieux
ou gibles macchabées entre encore en
enfer après ce paradis
[Musique]
les rubans inferno regardez ce regard
mais l'échelle enflammé céleste billes
céleste perles céleste sourisseau
bruissant dans la rame eut fumée infecte
et diablotins les corrections de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus